I don't think Putin targeted Hillary
Clinton specifically; certainly not in
the outset of the elections. The idea was
to undermine the trust in the very
institution of US election, whether it's
on the Republican side or Democratic
side or local side or federal side. That
did not start with the US elections. It
happened with Russia's involvement all
over Western Europe and Eastern Europe.
But as things progressed and it became
clear that Hillary Clinton was
going to be the nominee of the
Democratic Party, and especially since
she became the leading candidate, it was
particularly sweet for Putin to attack
her because there is bad blood between
them. In 2011, when mass anti-Putin
demonstrations swept throughout Russia,
he blamed the State Department for
organizing and paying for those
demonstrations and Hillary Clinton was
Secretary of State at the time.
So what do you think about Russian
involvement in the US presidential election?
Let us know in the comments section, and
also let us know what other topics you
want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.